We covered earlier this week that Texas made the
decision to open the state wide open letter rip,
canceling all guidelines, getting rid of the
mask mandate to. Now, of course, there has been
pushback and people saying this is incredibly
premature. It doesn't make any sense. So now
the Texas governor and lieutenant governor are
shifting into saying it's undocumented immigrants
and it's also Joe Biden to blame for covid
in Texas. Now, you might remember that all
throughout Donald Trump's presidency,
Trump and Texas Republicans were saying,
wow, thanks to Trump, we've shut down illegal
border crossings. Border crossings are at record
lows. The wall, which they didn't build, has
stopped border crossings. Crossings couldn't
possibly be lower. That's not convenient anymore.
Now they need something to blame for covid. So the
border crossings that they stopped those border
crossings are now to blame for covid in Texas.
Here's Republican Texas Governor Greg Abbott.
Earlier this week on Fox News, the Biden
administration was releasing illegal immigrant
illegal immigrants into our communities who had
covered the Bush administration, was spreading
covid in South Texas yesterday. And because of
their lack of constraint of testing and
quarantining people who'd come across
the border illegally, the Bush administration was
exposing Texans to covid that is Neanderthal type
approach to dealing with the COVA situation.
That is just barely coherent. If you
were wondering, did I have a brain
glitch? Did I misunderstand that? No,
it's just barely coherent. And then yesterday
morning, here's Republican Texas Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick, who previously said
grandma is willing to die for the stock market,
saying pretty much the same thing on Fox News.
And as Governor Abbott mentioned, I would call
Neanderthal thinking of allowing people
to cross the border illegally with covid
tested positive and put them on a bus,
allowing people to cross the border.
What is he talking about? They're just going
to keep repeating this lie over and over again,
as usual. And while there I mean, listen,
windmill's push around corvids. A respiratory
illness. I don't know. You're pushing all that
air around. Maybe that leads to infections to
now to attach some facts to all of this.
First of all, Biden isn't letting anyone in.
Biden's been president for five weeks.
Biden's presidency has had very little
effect one way or another, uncovered cases
so far other than ramping up vaccination,
which is starting to have an effect on cases.
Second, Mexico's per capita covid case rate
is about one sixth that of the United States. In
other words, the odds that someone coming from
Mexico has covid are one sixth of the odds that a
random American has covered. And in any case, if
Greg Abbott really believed this, that immigrants
were bringing covid to Texas from Mexico,
it still wouldn't make sense to cancel the mask
mandate and open everything. You'd want to be
protecting Texans from those supposed Mexicans
bringing covid over, which isn't happening anyway.
It was 100 percent predictable
that they were going to pull this.
They are pulling it and lots of Texans gleeful
for the removal of guidelines are going with it.
Many Texans are not happy with what's going on.
And there's an entire other Twitter movement
that is behind saying we do not support what Greg
Abbott is doing. Maybe we'll get to that later on
in the show. Let's take a quick break.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman,